alors darry cowl bonjour d'abord alors
vous vous êtes ici parce que vous venez
d'écrire un livre est assez surprenant
ça s'appelle le flambeur c'est publié
chez robert laffont
alors c'est surprenant parce que darry
cowl on vous connais vous êtes souvent
tenus au journal devant tout le temps au
cinéma ou à la télé puis vous êtes
souvent venu au journal pour parler pour
parler de tas de choses de films que
vous faites pour faire rire en général
et là vous fait plus rire du tout vous
racontez nous raconte et se raconte eu d
une petite tranche de ma vie qui a duré
entre 5 et 6 ans où j'étais au jeu
pratiqué le jeu de manière plus quatre
ans si vous était donc devenu le vrai
joueur leva joueurs qui qu'il est
capable en dix minutes de jouées à un
mois de salaire donc que le vrai drogué
le vrai malade et je raconte ce que
ressent ce que je subis un jouet dans
l'étau j'étais donc se droguer les
affres qu'il connaît les les moments
merveilleux bien sûr la féerie du jeu
mais ferry qui souvent est de courte
durée parce que les le malheureux plus
grands finalement que les moments je
vois je n'en vois qu'on est tous là très
bien dans ce livre comme je peux ah ben
oui c'est vrai tout retrait d'abdullah
loue également oui je trouve que c'est
bien le bon mais alors ce que et ça pose
quand même plein de questions j'ai envie
de vous poser d'abord comment ça
commence vous dites la durée cinq six
ans d'abord il faut préciser que vous
êtes un joueur repenti maintenant c'est
fini vous touchez plus rebondi ce
repenti non-joueurs d'irriguer ou
totalement totalement depuis 30 ans le
plus jeune et le plus touché la sentence
a entamé
donc je peux dire le suggérer non mais
alors comment ça a commencé sa phase a
commencé qu'il ya toujours un très bon
ami qui
qui qui entraîne comme comme le commun
comme dans la drogue
il sait les mauvaises fréquentations
comme la noix du doubs pas du tout tout
joueur comme tous drogués comme tout
alcoolique a le besoin
est ce pour cela le sentiment de se
déculpabiliser d'entraîner un jour comme
ça quelqu'un pour emmener derrière un
petit à un moment à perdre je viens de
voir c'est très amusant
puis alors il suit ça vous arrange pas
effectivement il se passe un peu de
phénomène est incompréhensible c'est que
très souvent les au début les joueurs
gagnent c'est bien que j'ai dû changer
une panne de 500 francs et j'ai dû
monter 7000 francs aussi bien avec cette
plaque donc c'est justement agréable de
voir une pac a fait plein de petits et
avoir l'envié d'avoir roger au
multicolores qui était je l'avais des
couleurs enfin les hommes là paris et
puis après j'ai joué au chemin de fer en
thriller genou la roulette non la
roulette sinon j'ai avenant jamais
multicolores chemin de fer le la web
trop lourd la roulette avons donné
qu'août laisse toutes les cinq minutes
alors le vrai joueur a besoin toujours
de manière à jouer très vite en plus
tard oui très mythique multicolores
c'était un jour où très vite ça va très
vite
coup dur peut durer trente cinq secondes
donc on peut gagner est aussi bien sûr
mais gagner très vite et beaucoup donné
beaucoup à vos débuts vous à velenje
beaucoup un peu comme tout le monde
n'ont pas beaucoup j'ai jamais été très
très chanceux n'avait jamais gagné
beaucoup jamais non j'étais même un gars
est plutôt passable
j'ai ma vie travail à moi j'ai une
chance considérable lorsqu'il connaît
même mal élevé par moments mais au jeu
j'étais d'ailleurs ça y est ça c'est ce
qui a fait que je n'ai arrêté de jouer
un jour parce que je n'avais très les a
cédées faire c'est vrai si vous aviez
gagné peut-être que vous auriez enfin si
vous avez gagné plus souvent nizon parce
qu'on finit toujours par terre délation
mais vous aviez gagné plus souvent
auriez continuer plus longtemps à y
aller joueur qui gagne qui sont souvent
ça reste mystérieux mais n'importe
comment non parce que j'en avais assez
de perdre tout ce temps droit les tapis
vert ce et puis j'en avais assez de
faire de la peine à ma femme je me
rendais compte que les amis ses cartes à
jouer
un petit à petit prix dire qu'on perd un
peu plus que son argent on perd aussi
une partie de sa vie on perd d'abord on
perd son temps parce que on peut pas
récupérer le temps devant tapis vert le
temps perdu et irrécupérable pour moi je
veux dire en 100 ans jimmy vie moi
écrire le livre mais comme rien on dit
rien ne se perd dans la vie en tout cas
séduit ces six années où j'ai joué
mettons que ça mais servi de nous pour
écrire ce livre donc de travaux décès et
j'ai mis huit mois l'écrire donc j'ai
écrit deux livres en cinq ans et s'est
dit me vois pas ce que dit il ya des
gens qui parlent très bien du jeu par
exemple françoise sagan qui elle aussi
est une joueuse impénitent un qui a été
et qui essaient interdit aux imams et
calvino elle en parle bien et avec
tendresse vous gardez l'espèce de
tendresse pour le jeu d'une fin du
talk-show non pas du tout moi quand je
le mari de rentrer maintenant les salles
de jeux comme ça pour regarder acheter
vous irez quand même avec comme ça non
mais je rentrais copier journée dans une
quincaillerie ou une épicerie mons ne
fait pas plus d'effet que ça va pas du
tout là je vois il modifiait
complètement je suis devenu et mais je
vois toujours les savanes tous versé 27
lignes les les identités ont changé mais
je vois les noms google dans sa joie les
mêmes tics je vois les gagnants le
bonheur dans leurs yeux je vois les
perdants qui souffrent jeu je retrouve
tout ce que j'ai connu il ya trente ans
alors un jeu vous aviez tout perdu vous
risquiez votre vie ça allait très mal
dans votre vie privée alors vous avez
décidé d'arrêter complètement
oui c'est l'accumulation de plusieurs
choses on constate ici mes amis et bien
d'abord on demande la protection de la
police des moeurs on se fait à 10,1 il
vous est interdit
bien sûr cette élection dure cinq ans
tous les cinq ans renouvelables et après
je crois au bout d'un troisième cet avis
est donc j'ai vu interdire pas de
garanties mais enfin je sorte de grille
parce qu'un joueur se jurent tous les
jours 320 par jour d'arrêter sa cousine
à défaut que je joue si je gagne je joue
d'arrêter il serait sous serment 320 par
jour s'ils jouent tous les jours et si
vous pendant six ans a fait beaucoup de
serment jeter à la poubelle mais un jour
j'ai dit j'arrête et puis vous avez tenu
le coup c'est une couveuse et en plus
parce qu'une j'ai rencontré une dame
bien charmant dont le prénom et erland
quelques jours ma femme depuis
depuis donc trente ans et j'ai senti que
il ne te laisserai pas d'avoir comme
compagnon un joueur de trouver que sa
maman était une vraie joueuse aussi donc
elle les laissait un peu les la ville et
les problèmes qu'occasionne ne peut
fonctionner à un vrai jouet et donc ça
que les trévières donc elle a fait
pencher la balance et depuis tous les
jours je gagne du fait que je ne joue
plus mais en fait vous jouiez pour
combler un vide dans votre vie louis
n'ayant pas moi j'ai pas lu mon père qui
était un être merveilleux à l'âge de 8
ans et n'ont jamais connu ma vraie mère
j'ai connu une fausse mère je soupçonne
que c'est par manque de l'affection que
j'ai que je plongeais là dedans comme je
pense que beaucoup de drogués plonge
dans la drogue parce qu'ils ont un
manque quelque part c'est dément un
manque de règles en face ils ont
commencé mais moi je pense que c'est pas
manque d'effectivité demande érection
certaines marques que j'ai eu la dent
mais ceci dit bon c'est merveilleux
c'est une aventure que qui peut-être
nous permettra de haut de gamme
elle m'a permis de découvrir un nouveau
virus c'est d'écrire général du patient
quand maintenant je tape à la machine
c'est une passe à ses larges pas mal là
tu sais pas pourquoi vous êtes un peu
comme zéro non non la photo qui remonte
à 40 ans mais à ce point là on allait
mourir ce merveilleux mais presse c'est
vrai merci beaucoup d'alcool merci de ce
témoignage dont qui s'appelle le
flambeur et qui est publié chez robert
laffont
à bientôt d'avis favorables